[Music]
time now for pft on yahoo sports peter
king and mike florio the big stories in
the national football league and one of
the big stories in the nfc the saints
who seem to be locked in on the one seed
losing to the eagles the packers beating
the lions now the packers hold that one
seed by virtue of a week three tie
breaker the win over new orleans in new
orleans peter
the prospect of the packers even with
the stands empty the tundra is still
frozen teams having to come and play
outdoors
in green bay how important is this and
how likely does it make green bay
getting to the super bowl if they emerge
with the one seed when the regular
season ends
you know i thought that
that was the most self-aware and team
aware
thing uh that aaron rodgers has said in
a while after the game the other night
uh in detroit that
basically you know this is a team that
would have a huge advantage
if everybody had to come through green
bay
in the month of january because mike
think about this okay think about the
teams
that might have to come through
uh green bay i mean new orleans
eventually probably
if they would have to come through green
bay obviously warm weather team dome
team
the rams who i think
really
when push comes to shove in a year like
this
defense is really going to play a
premium
that is a defense that i think is going
to take the rams far this year and then
obviously arizona
uh you know which could
uh on a given sunday can beat anybody so
there are so many teams that wouldn't be
used to
uh you know seven degree wind chill with
howling winds and having to play a
competent football game in those
conditions so
look it's it's fashionable to say the
crowd you know not having a crowd really
uh you know is a big deal and there's no
home field advantage i can tell you
there would be a home field advantage in
january if the games are in green bay
the packers have this weird knack for
periodically showing up flat and you
hear about it after the fact when they
lose that they didn't have energy they
weren't ready to play typically it
happens to them on the road but earlier
this year they were flat in multiple of
their home games i think they figured
out their way past and they presumably
would be past it in the postseason
there's one team though that fascinates
me as a potential visitor to lambeau
field in january and that's the tampa
bay buccaneers remember all those years
where the buccaneers have never won a
game where the temperature at kickoff
was below 40 degrees well now they've
got tom brady the ultimate northeast
outdoor quarterback who has sworn off
ever living in the northeast again now
he's gotten a taste of tampa but if they
have to go to lambeau field
not that he can do all that much to
prepare his guys who may not be
accustomed to those conditions to deal
with it but he sets the shining example
for the rest of them and he's the last
guy on the roster who's going to be
deterred by the cold the wind the snow
the whatever they may encounter if they
have to play in green bay and they beat
the packers 38 to 10 in tampa
i mean who knows how it would play out
or anything mike but the one
you just said it you know i the one one
of the reasons why i did not include the
bucks
in what i was saying about the teams is
that okay look so they've been
practicing in the warm all year
look at all the guys on that team who
are used to playing in cold weather and
i'll take obviously tom brady
uh two of their receivers chris godwin
from penn state scotty miller from
bowling green i mean these are guys who
grew up
playing in cold weather it's not really
going to be
uh you know an earth shaker to them and
so i sort of look at this
and i say
i think tampa bay would be well suited
to go up there and play them you know
particularly
if they get on a little bit of a roll
and brady really gets great chemistry
with his receiving group
nine years ago the packers were 15-1
with the number one seed and the giants
went in in the divisional round and
stunned them so it's going to be an
interesting play-off field whoever the
number one seed is in the nfc that's it
for pft on yahoo sports we'll see you
next time
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports